southpark fans will be pleased to know
that Matt Stone and Trey Parker the
creators of the show are working closely
with Ubisoft in order to create a
southpark experience that we've come to
expect senior producer Jason Schroeder
told the PlayStation Blog they're really
really involved we have daily calls and
I'm down there a few times a month just
constantly trying to make sure they're
getting the comedy they want into the
game and making sure that it all makes
sense moment to moment Schroeder added
that stone and Parker are gamers so
quote there's a really easy common
language he further explained that some
of stone and Parker's best comedy comes
with deadlines and pressure hanging over
their heads separate from the game they
truly make each episode of south park in
just six days Schroeder said it's from
that pressure they get really relevant
really timely jokes the video game cycle
by comparison is brutally long for them
it sounds like the fractured butthole
will feature plenty of Matt and Trey's
unedited humor there's hopefully going
to be some stuff in there that people
will say how did that make it through
classification Schroeder said in case
you've forgotten 2014 stick of truth had
anal probing abortion and swastikas how
will fractured butthole push the
envelope even further you'll have to use
your imagination for now but for more on
South Park the fractured butt hole stay
tuned to gamespot